good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy wednesday
hi everyone how are you doing hey claude
how are you doing hello jacqueline happy
hump day to you and your loved ones i am
doing splendiferously i'm
so tired yesterday was the longest day
of my life
um but i'm excited to be here because we
have got a bang out
drag out
episode what's the phrase i don't know
what you're trying to say but we do have
a blockbuster episode for you today if
we may just walk you through it really
quickly
obviously we have the fast life stories
and you know what they are extremely
varied and they look forward to getting
your take on them we're varied queens we
are then we'll be recapping real house
eyes of new jersey another great episode
from the ladies last night can't
freaking wait also i watched the first
episode of gilded age yesterday
i don't have enough to say to but i'll
put it in the tv segment because who the
[ __ ] hairs yeah
then you sat down yesterday
with sophia franklin and conducted one
of the best podcast interviews i've ever
watched like you know how i've been like
looking for podcast content to watch
well your
interview with sophia was like meant for
me i was your target audience and i
thoroughly enjoyed it i was cracking up
the two of you are so funny there was so
much good tea information lessons wisdom
being shared spilled and i just enjoyed
it so much i'm so excited for everyone
to hear it well let me tell
you getting emotional emotional let me
tell you that i don't think i've ever
been like so taken by someone's presence
in my life i had never met sophia before
obviously like i've dm'd and texted with
her a bunch but never met in person
and
she is first of all she's gorgeous but
she's just like this she really is that
girl like she's just so
she has this great presence about her we
were we were having like technical
difficulties so for like 20 minutes we
just sat there and like talked and we
were like tears in our eyes hysterical
laughing she's so funny and i think like
no matter where you ended up like on
what side of the call her daddy divorce
um you should listen to the episode
because i think her pov and honestly i
didn't want to get so much in to call
her daddy i didn't want her to
feel uncomfortable but she was really
open so i just let her say her piece i
wasn't really planning on going that
deep but she was open
and there's some good tea in there
obviously but also i don't know i just
think don't write sofia off she's
extremely funny her point of view is
super interesting she's been through
a lot and i think you'll
i think you'll see things differently
after the episode
or if anything you'll just have an
appreciation for someone who's really
funny and who can laugh at herself and
fufia yanklin like it was just it was
really
like an amazing experience and i also
podcasted with her for her podcast and i
do believe that comes out today and
there was some also juicy tidbits on
there as well
more content for me to consume i'm so
excited and also i i think you could say
she's textbook everything of the sort i
think those are the words you're looking
for
a hundred percent like she was just
sitting across from me like putting on
her charlotte tilbury like nude lip
liner and i was like this is a girl like
i want to be like she's just fabulous
wow i'm wearing charlotte tilbury today
too me too it just wasn't the same it
just doesn't look the same
no it was different like she did it
differently and it was so cool and i
just i felt like i was in high school
like with one of the popular girls like
she was just so
in person like so radiant and so funny
and i was like i was like giddy when i
left because i think she's thinking
about moving back to new york and i just
wanted to like get drinks you know yeah
that's the best feeling also speaking of
getting drinks it looks like you had a
really interesting evening last night so
let me just tell you about my day share
with the class okay tell us about your
day i went to the studio um to podcast
with you
and we haven't been to the studio in
months and i just went through every
package it was literally a warehouse so
i was sweating like an animal we had
mattresses nutrition bars like all these
packages i was sweating like an animal
then i sat down and recorded melissa
gorga's podcast which was really fun
like a lot of jersey tea
um and i think it comes out this week or
next i'm not 100 sure
then sophia got there we did our segment
then we did sophia's segment i came home
got dressed showered and i went to a
torah class you know a little tamar
judge bible study moment um which i
haven't been to in a while i used to go
to a lot before covid and it was really
um like an eye-opening experience i
guess i didn't realize like i have it
take i don't know what it was but like
it it was an
eye-opening experience because i
realized i think i've been very
disconnected from my faith like i i was
just like
i was sitting at the torah class and it
all felt so far and when i used to do
this so frequently and i felt like
guilty
and actually the torah class was really
perfect for me
because and i just wanted to share i
think it's it's obviously a jewish class
but there was like the overall message
that i think is nice for whatever
religion you are
um she was basically saying like
judaism or you can apply it to whatever
religion you are like faith is like an
inheritance
there's four kids the dad leaves them 10
million each and even if there's one kid
who has a lot of money already he's
still entitled to that 10 million
dollars just as much as the person who's
not the most well-off and it's like your
faith is an inheritance like even if you
have an abundance of it like you always
want more and even if you are not like
the most involved and spiritual you've
been like you're still entitled we are
all children of god like we're all
entitled to that
inheritance and no matter what spectrum
of the religious scale you are like we
are all god's people it was and i was
just like feeling guilty because like i
never go to the torah classes and she
was like speaking directly to my soul
that's claudia that's so beautiful thank
you for sharing that little tidbit yeah
i think that um i think that especially
in covet a lot of people have felt like
disconnected from faith i mean on a very
technical level like not being able to
go to a house to church yeah to a torah
class so i'm glad that you reconnected
it sounded like you had a very balanced
day you know podcast podcast podcast
torah tyler c
yes so then i went over to tyler c's
apartment
um and i had to like skedaddle out of
the torah class just a little early and
they're like where are you going i'm
like i have to go to my boyfriend's
apartment sorry um
and he's on this new tv show called the
real dirty dancing
and i watched last week and then this
week's episode he invited a couple
people over to watch and it was really
fun and he's so good on the show and
he's like so proud of it and everyone
should watch it's a really cute show and
then we just like hung out ate pizza and
i was just like one of tyler's girls you
know
that's so cute you know what's such a
random coincidence this always happens
to me on my time hop but i was on time
hop and
two years ago today we went to tyler no
two years ago yesterday we went to tyler
c's apartment for that party that time
isn't that so weird we were there on
this yesterday
you're on the same day you were there on
the same day two years apart
no that's it's my tyler anniversary
that's beautiful do you think tyler sees
the person who wrote in about having a
threesome
with you in bed with me and ben
it's possible i don't want to you know
we really take pride in our deer toaster
segment being completely anonymous so i
don't want to out anyone but it's
entirely possible yeah i i agree well
i'm so glad that you had such a
well-rounded day really and that we get
we get the fruits of your labor all this
content how was your day preggio
thanks for asking my day was the same as
usual actually not really i skipped over
my nap because i thought it would enable
me to go to bed earlier and i was like
that sounds like a nice idea so i got
into bed at 10 30 and of course i was up
till one still
but i did go to the doctor yesterday i
have another appointment today and we
got to see like the sonogram stuff but
baby was hiding we didn't honestly we
didn't see [ __ ] and i was so [ __ ] shy
this is the baby
i'm shy
[Laughter]
um and i was so tired that i was like
closing my eyes on the table i was like
there was nothing to see here
by kevin wilson okay so uh literally
just it was then quiet then i spoke to
you then i watched your interview with
sophia which was really the highlight of
my day
then i watched gilded age real houses of
new jersey
usual business
nothing to reply i watch new jersey also
we'll talk about it in the tv recap um i
actually watched the interview with
sophia when i got home yesterday like to
relive it and then i watched it again
this morning i'm like obsessed with it
well if you're listening as a podcast
it'll be at the end of this episode and
if you're watching on youtube it will
already be up on youtube like before
this video goes up so hopefully you will
have already treated yourself to it yeah
it's a real treat
it's a sweet treat
um
so i think without further a
did it do where are you
where is dew i've heard he's out of the
house
no he's home he's scratching at my door
um he wants to come inside with mom but
mom's busy
damn so i guess without further ado
at the door
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
that's it nutrition that's it makes
delicious convenient plant-based super
snacks from only the purest ingredients
and that's it all of their snacks are
natural non-gmo and preservative free
with no added purees juices or
concentrates that's it they offer a
broad range of convenient on-the-go
snacks with all items containing six
ingredients or less they make fruit
snacks that are actually made from 100
real fruit which is a mind-blowing
concept
their snacks are school safe because
they're completely free from the top 12
allergens
that's it makes snacks without secrets
so the ingredients on the front of the
packaging match the ingredients on the
back they're fruit bars which is their
top-selling bar in america which we have
a huge stockpile of at the studio that i
was eating all day yesterday um they
contain 100 fruit and they're so good
their simple recognizable ingredients
come in portable convenient formats you
can find that sit nationwide at your
local starbucks at major retailers such
as target walmart whole foods in costco
and online at amazon and that's it
fruit.com head over to thatsitfruit.com
toast and use the code toast to receive
20 off your first order that's it
fruit.com toast and use code toast to
receive 20 off your first order
today's episode is also brought brought
to you by third love one of our favorite
brands here at the morning toast in og
sponsor you guys know how in love we are
with their bras because not only are
they great quality but they know how to
fit a breast and i think the greatest
asset third love has is their fit quiz
their fitting room quiz because i think
a lot of us are walking around wearing
the wrong bra size i know i was for like
at least 10 years and it wasn't until i
took this really in-depth quiz on third
love about the shape of my boob are my
cups flowing over
is my band too tight it's good questions
and then i realized what my true size
was and i was wearing the totally wrong
size and then they have so many
different bra options
so the fitting room quiz makes it easy
to find a bra that actually fits
there it's like a personal shopper but
better because it focuses on size breast
shape current fit issues your personal
style and they have the love your fit
guaranteed so if you don't love your fit
you can exchange and return and they're
free for 30 uh for 60 days excuse me
their team of expert fit stylist is
available to chat via text
and answer all your questions and their
latest deco lace collection is designed
to make you feel sexy 365 days of the
year putting on this collection feels
like indulging in yourself every day
third love does comfort so you can do
you so obviously their broads are
amazing but they also have underwear
activewear wear and feel good all day
wear that are designed to hug better
hold stronger and support longer third
love obsesses over each stitch so you
never have to think about how something
feels looks or wears the hundred
thousand five star reviews don't lie
feeling is believing upgrade to everyday
pieces that love your body as much as
you do right now you can get twenty
percent off your first order at
thirdlove.com toast that's 20 off at
thirdlove.com
toast now i did want to say one thing
um i apologize for what's going on
behind me it is wednesday everyone knows
that's the day i do my laundry um and i
just want to let you know theo has
entered the building so we can
officially get started we can officially
get started i saw that behind you it's
the changing of the sheets very exciting
it's the changing of the guards
exactly
okay let's get into the stories
every time you cough or choke i'm like
it's time call zach
oh my god i called margot today because
i had something so juicy to tell her
that i'll tell you afterwards um
and she didn't pick up and i'm like if
you don't call me back right now and she
goes jackie's in labor oh my god i'm
like you would be hearing it from me no
i would be hearing it the same way you
do totally actually if we were like on
the toast you might have a you know a
fast track to knowing but it's the same
thing here like every time i'm like zach
like asking for like you know him to
bring me a glass of water he's like
he's like you can and literally he'll
come in to like or he'll be in the other
room and i'm like ugh like just sighing
just a general malaysia as one does and
he's like you can't do that i'm like i
can't do what
speak breathe
literal breathe i just want to say if lc
is a true content creator he would know
the timing for him to come would be on
the podcast because literally that would
be so
meta so everything like i just think
it's something else you should think
about if my water broke during the
podcast
so sickening so sickening but depending
on like when your water breaks and such
we could keep podcasting because i have
time like you do have a lot of time
before you need to go to the hospital
would you ever imminent it would depend
where we're at in the show because then
also i need to get the episode up like
i'm just going to sit here in the
morning right right oh my god that's
that's like i remember when i was a kid
i think the first like labor on reality
tv i saw
was kourtney kardashian's
first birth and her water breaks and
we're used to seeing the movies oh look
at the bag in the car yeah and she takes
a shower and blows out her hair i'm like
this [ __ ] is crazy but that's actually
what happens that's actually what
happens you spend a good amount of time
at home you see how far apart your
attraction your contractions are once
they get to a certain point you go to
the hospital so
there's a chance if we were podcasting i
would just sit here in my in my amniotic
fluid oh and and and we'd literally
and we'd have contractions with you like
right like
yeah
that's not a contraction i think the
labor contractions are like doubled over
in pain for about one minute and then
you get a few minutes
yeah
that sounds horrible that's good
godspeed thank you well let's get into
the stories our first story some hosting
news sherry shepherd will be named the
permanent guest host of the wendy
williams show
sherry shepherd is set to be named the
permanent guest host of the wendy
williams show following her health
hiatus in september 2021 beginning in
september 2022 the former view co-host
will take over the series regularly
however one source tells page six that
the move will not be forever tmz reports
that producers will monitor wendy's
progress between now and september which
is when they would premiere the show's
15th season
if wendy is healthy enough to host by
then she'll be welcomed back with open
arms if not sherry will take over and
producers will consider a name change
for the talk show
wow well obviously um it's not going to
be sherry on the wendy show
but i have to say
they've been having a large like a huge
rotation of people i know michael
rappaport heather mcdonald jerry
o'connell also did you see heather
mcdonald posted a video of her faint oh
okay she's such an icon okay um
so they had a lot of leo remini i saw a
very funny segment that she did so i
think sherry shepard is great she
obviously has a ton of hosting
experience she was on the view
um and she's also just like
like an american icon honestly so i
think it's a great selection but i am
confused i just feel like we've been in
this limbo with wendy for so long
and i do feel like it's time
to just like move on like this they're
like she's a permanent host but it's
temporary we'll reassess it in november
like which is it no she's the permanent
guest host right like it's just
confusing i agree that it's confusing
but i'm sure you know they i'm sure
they're reticent to change the entire
show considering it's been such a
success people love wendy and even if
this is like a
slow you know
it's ultimately it it will no longer be
the well wendy william show i think they
probably want to ease the audience into
it as opposed to just being like wendy's
over here's your new show you know and i
think they want to just retain that
audience so making the changes
incremental
might be
easier for the audience to digest yeah i
mean i have do have a feeling my gut is
just saying wendy will not return and i
do feel like it's the end of an era like
she is there's no show she's not like
other hosts there's really no show like
wendy like she's incredibly unfiltered
borderline offensive sometimes but like
it's refreshing because everyone is
not like that so
she if she if this is the end of her
show career i do feel like she will be
missed and there will be like a huge gap
in the market and whoever comes in will
be great but there is no one like wendy
honestly love her or hate her like you
have to acknowledge she's not like other
hosts
no and it's so hard to have continued
success in this space so whatever she's
been doing she's obviously doing
something right and
it definitely is signals the end of an
era though i do think sherry shepard
will do a great job
me too i just i also feel like we
haven't gotten like a really
like good understanding of what wendy's
going through so i just want to wish her
well you know but i am confused
yes i i agree and i hope that she takes
the time that she needs and even if once
she does start feeling better that
doesn't necessarily mean like you should
go back to working five like it's a
taxing job mentally physically
emotionally and sometimes you just need
uh to be not working agreed and i'm sure
whatever she's going through like the
stress of being a daytime host was not
helping
yeah
for sure wishing her the best truly
truly okay our next story james
it's something that you just mentioned
i'm just going to scoot it on up to the
top
the stories are kind of out of order
today there's no like usually i try to
um
have them like make a bit of sense but
they don't make sense today the the
the chronology
heather mcdonald
don't don't explain yourself you are an
artist
and what you do is beautiful and
important and i don't really feel like
you have to explain yourself honestly
thank you claudia
but heather mcdonald is posting a video
of herself on of her onstage faint that
resulted in a skull fracture
so over the weekend actually wait jackie
this story actually should have been
slated behind the wendy story because
the video of heather fainting reminded
me so much of the video of wendy
williams fainting they're identical yes
oh my god watching someone feign is
shocking
i hate it oh my gosh
shared video footage of her fainting
spell that took place on stage over the
weekend in tempe arizona the comedian
fell after taking the stage for a
stand-up set on saturday night and was
later admitted to the hospital with a
skull fracture on tuesday she shared a
clip of the moment along with the jokes
that preceded it about how she's been
covered vaccinated she has the flu shot
she has the shingle shot and how jesus
loves her
and then she
fainted
okay heather's such an icon first of all
like the fact that she posted this video
because it's not like a super flattering
video like
it's and she could have it's not like
this was being aired like with the wendy
video that video just got shared and
shared because it happened on air this
is a video that the comedy club recorded
a lot of clubs can record your show for
you which is a comedian is really
helpful to re-watch the show over and so
she didn't have to share this with us
she didn't but she did and that's why
she's an icon i think the last the last
thing she says being jesus loves me it's
like you actually can't write comedy
that good honestly like she said clearly
jesus loves me the most seriously
and then and i think in the audience
they didn't realize that they didn't
move they didn't move they didn't flinch
because they thought it was part of this
bit because it all like together is
comical
it's scary and serious but if you're
sitting in a comedy club like you would
probably would imagine it's part of the
bit
so literally like i watched a video a
couple times over and i'm watching
different people in the audience and
nobody
moved a muscle like not a flinch oh my
god and first of all you can see really
where she fractures her skull she goes
down hard on her the back of her head
and she must be in a lot of pain so like
wishing her like a speedy recovery
that's
and i think for whatever type of
performer you are like you always get
her like i always think like what if i
have diarrhea on stage like my stomach
starts to hurt and i get like sweaty
shawn mendes vibes you know that's my
personal but i think a lot of people
think like what if i faint and i always
say like if i go on and like i can't
remember what i'm about to say like one
of these days i'm just gonna fake faint
um you just know if you come to my show
and i faint like it's fraudulent just
like stop then they'll be playing this
clip when you really do faint and then
this will be another ironic moment so
take that back
i've never fainted i take it back sorry
i do take it back i'll i would actually
never fake fame that's disgusting um you
also wouldn't be good at fake fainting
because you wouldn't commit to the fall
you would like you know um buffer your
head or something yeah and we would all
know
no it's true because like in order for
it to be like a real thing like every
muscle in your body like everything just
shuts down like yeah you're completely
limb
yeah you wouldn't be able to commit to
limp
limp limb limbs are limp yeah
have you fainted once in high school
right i do believe i caught you
yeah because i donated blood and i was
just too small and i shouldn't have i
literally you guys i'll never forget i'm
on the third floor walking by the
elevator jackie's walking this way like
towards me what great timing that we
just happened to be near one another she
donated blood and she don't look so good
and she's like a little
she's a little green and she's like
wobbling and i'm like hey sis you good
boom falls falls on the floor our
history teacher dr deutsch came and
picked you up and then you threw up on
him
no so what happened was so then they
came pick me up and they put me in a
wheelchair just to like move me around
and the nurse like i'm sorry this is
just like some trauma gave me a bag to
throw up in
and so i was sitting in the wheelchair i
threw up in the bag and the bag didn't
have a [ __ ] bottom it had a huge hole
it was a bottomless bag i threw up all
over my lap disgusting
it was like and everyone in the school
was buzzing about it was like biggest
drama it was in between classes everyone
was like flooding out and they're
shuffling there she was and i mean i
tried to do a good deed obviously i
haven't donated blood since i'm i'm
clearly not a candidate
no you're not equipped um but is that
the only time you fainted yes that's the
only time i fainted
it's one of my biggest fears like it
looks so scary
i i it's one of my biggest fears
yeah
yeah especially i mean for heather and
obviously she's joking about and she's
back on her podcast so i'm sure she's
doing okay but still like a very scary
situation
so scary but she's like she's really
like such a seasoned comedian that she
can make a joke out of this because like
some people might feel embarrassed by it
some people might not want to show the
video and she's just like an icon and a
legend she's a podcaster she knows the
importance of sharing content with her
audience and i just have so much respect
for heather mcdonald always but today in
particular
agreed completely
okay our next story is really funny it's
a story for you
french montana can't believe that he
once met the tinder swindler and he has
the photo to prove it so french montana
posted a selfie of him and simon lev aka
the tinder levi
levi get it right don't get it and
actually that's not even his real name
and i think it's actually really
disrespectful that this article is using
his real name his name is shimon hayoot
okay so
he posted a picture with shio shimon
haiyu while he was pretending to be
simon lev um and he was so surprised
that he's rubbed elbows with the frog
star i guess he's been watching the
documentary also and he found the
picture and said i can't believe i met
the swindler laughing emoji okay i have
so many questions about this one because
it appears as though they're on a
commercial flight and we all know simon
leviev never flew commercial
two this picture just was posted and
taken so out of context i think a lot of
people were like oh my god they're
together right now
i actually didn't realize until this
moment that this was like an old picture
that
that french montana like found yeah
because simon is back to his was he's
out of prison he's flying on jets again
nobody knows what he does for a living
he's got all these beautiful women
around him so i thought this was
something happening now but i guess it's
not
no i guess it's not but it's so funny
because i feel like oftentimes with
these uh schemesters and fraudsters they
taught they taught these like celebrity
connections while they're doing their
scheme and of course like the
celebrities are like shudder to things
like i don't [ __ ] know this person
how did my name right it tingles with
them and like to
then imagine being french montana and
like watching he probably watched this
documentary and then like saw that he's
actually met this person
and leaning into it is so funny as
opposed to like pretending you know
like it didn't happen yeah every once in
a while we're watching like a
documentary and some celebrity makes
their way in there i forget what i was
just watching and i think it was gwyneth
paltrow wasn't in it like it was like
her cousin they did oh oh oh we work we
work yeah yeah they did an interview the
wife was like this wellness freak yeah
yeah so every now and then it comes up
and it's so funny and you're right like
seeing french lean into it
is fun
and this just further you know cements
why i have like a special place in my
heart for french montana always and
forever
yeah that is really funny you saw that
they're making a movie about wework like
a real it's with um anne hathaway is
playing the the wife
and i forget who's playing adam but i
mean if i remember correctly when we
watched the documentary and then
recapped it i do believe the overall
message was like is this a story worth
telling um and now it's a story being
told again so i mean i'll watch it of
course but i don't know i just didn't
think it was like that crazy of a
documentary
i agree i didn't think it was that crazy
of a story
that's just me i have a high bar because
i watch locked up abroad you know
yeah they should make that into a movie
[Laughter]
are you ready for our next story
only if it's a story that's brought to
you by zip recruiter
it is
actually it's the perfect story for zip
recruiter you'll see why you almost
would think we planned these things like
we kind of should but we don't
according to the latest research ninety
percent of employers plan to make
enhancing the employee experience a top
priority in 2022 after all a happy
workplace is a key to attracting and
keeping great employees and if you need
to add more employees to your team their
zip recruiter their matching technology
helps you find the right people for your
roles fast and right now you can try
ziprecruiter for free at zipruder.com
toast ziprecruiter uses its powerful
technology to find and match the right
candidates up with your job then it
proactively presents these candidates to
you you can easily review these
recommended candidates and invite your
top choices to apply for your job which
encourages them to apply faster it's no
wonder ziprecruiter is the number one
rated hiring site in the us based on g2
ratings
zip recruiters technology is so
effective that four out of five
employers who post on ziprecruiter get a
quality candidate within the first day
so find the right employers for your
workplace with zip recruiter try it for
free at this exclusive address
ziprecruiter.comtoast.ziprecruiter.com
t-o-a-s-t zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire
well amy schneider's former employer is
going to be needing to use zip recruiter
to film she's going to be meeting she's
going to be meeting
because amy schneider has quit her day
job after the girl historic jeopardy run
so the jeopardy champ announced on
tuesday that she recently quit her day
job as software engineering manager
following her historic run on the game
show where she netted about 1.4 million
dollars she said some of you may have
heard but i quit my day job yesterday
it's a bit nerve-wracking to pivot from
software engineer to public figure i
guess
but regardless of the outcome i'm so
excited to spend the next couple years
at least tackling this new challenge
yeah of course i mean even if so she won
like
i think over a million dollars after
taxes 1.382
so after taxes it's like 700 grand
that's a lot of money you can definitely
live off of that but also people are
obsessed with her she's like a trans
icon now she's a scholarly queen there's
i'm a myriad of opportunities she also
probably has a pretty good following on
social media um and she's big in the
academic space so if not if not now like
she can always go back to her job if she
wants to or a software job but like why
not take the bull by the horns
keep going you know off the momentum and
see what you could do with your life amy
get it girl i support this i don't know
i kind of had the opposite take
like
yeah
i just i i mean i guess i don't follow
her on social media so i don't know like
what she's doing and like how she's
popping off but
like she's like so smart she has this
like big job and now she's gonna quit
and become an influencer like it just
makes you sad by the way that's not what
she's gonna do she's not becoming an
influencer what is she doing
she's definitely um
she's just gonna be like a ken jennings
in a sense like
i don't know exactly what she's gonna do
but she's not gonna be selling fabfitfun
boxes she's like a well-respected
woman in science and woman in academia
and she'll do because
because of jeopardy yes
yes
okay i don't know she's gonna do
speaking motivational speaking she's
gonna definitely work with the lgbtq
plus community
i think that it's not what you think it
is it's gonna be it's gonna be huge
i don't know if it's gonna be huge but i
also i i don't really know i just feel
like maybe she could have taken a
sabbatical just to like ride this wave i
don't know how far this wave will take
her even thinking about ken jennings
like did he wind up getting the job he's
still in the rotation of people so like
what does he do all the other days of
the week there's stuff out there it's
not stuff we're familiar with because
we're not scholars but there's you could
be famous in academic circles i'm sure i
know that's possible i just don't know
anyone who is and it pays the bills of
course merit scholars you know things
like that
okay i mean i just to me it's like if
she has this job that she's liked for a
very long time and then she gets this
cushion
of 1.3 million dollars after taxes and
you know fees and everything um that's
like a nice that's just a great
a nice step but life becomes
one person's
that's one that's how one person could
do it but she took the nation by storm
and i think she's really becoming i
think she's like a huge inspiration in
the gay community like i think that
there's so much she could do
and yes she could you know have a simple
wonderful life with her millions
or she could get after it take those
opportunities wouldn't you
i don't know what the opportunities are
so i can't say me neither but i know
they're out there okay okay i just like
i don't know i
it's just crazy everyone just wants to
be an influencer you know no i wouldn't
don't put amy down like that that's not
what she's doing
okay i hope i'm proven wrong really i'm
you know what i really like i don't know
what
what the opportunities are but like i
know that there are like she's gonna do
like
college commencements like i just know
it
just because she won jeopardy
jackie she didn't win jeopardy she is
the second
highest ranked jeopardy winner
she i'm sure has a myriad of stories to
tell things she's been through she could
write a book she could write a book you
know i mean i need to just because maybe
maybe you're not like the target demo
because you don't watch jeopardy like
doesn't mean she's an inspiration to a
lot of people i need to do motivational
speaking what motivational speaking
jennings does with his time
motivational speaking for sure
for sure what does ken jennings do with
his time look it up it's a hard question
to find out let me see personal life
no career
i i
okay career
outside jeopardy okay so it says other
game show appearances american crossword
puzzle tournament connect connections i
guess that's like his own show
connections
um tuesday trivia emails controversial
tweets omnibus podcast and washington
state honor oh she could start a podcast
she could start a podcast
where she's talking about all things you
know
scholarly
yeah no there's
a big
a big market for this thing we're not
look at ours
right we're not academic so like i don't
really know like what you could do but
i'm telling you there's something okay i
hope that you're right and that i'm
wrong
i think i am and i think that never
happens but i think this might be one of
the few times where i'm right and you're
wrong okay cool are you ready for our
fifth and final story
i am because you want to know why
it's the final story
wishing you the best amy schneider on
your influencing jer
and that's a magic number
that was like my breathy version like my
ariana grande version i liked it a lot
it was kind of stunning
our fifth and final story i have to get
your take on this because uh nbc sports
is responding to leslie jones who was
taking herself out of the olympics
commentary running apparently it was she
said i'm starting to feel like this
should be my last olympics that i live
tweet i know another celebrity bitching
but i'm tired of fighting the folks who
don't want me to do it they block my
videos and they get folks who think they
can do it like me and i'm tired of
fighting them i love the athletes and
they love me doing it and i know y'all
love it but now it's just gotten too
hard and no one is fighting for or with
me so i guess i'll leave it to the
professionals but thank you for the love
then nbc responded saying that it was an
error that led to her belief that they
didn't want her doing this they said
this was the result of a third-party
error and the situation has been
resolved she is free to do her social
media posts as she has done in the past
she's a super fan of the olympics and we
are super fans of her
this rubs me the wrong way i saw that i
saw that leslie posted that and it
wasn't that i didn't believe her but i'm
like
i'm like how are they blocking you like
i just didn't understand and now look at
nbc fully validating her story
corroborating and i'm sorry i doubted
you leslie you're a hero and an icon an
american
woman who deserves freedom of platform
and i support
agreed now that i think about it what
was probably happening is if she was
filming the tv and commentating then
maybe she was getting like they were
taking them down through copyright and
that's obviously frustrating for her
when she's trying to speak on the
situation but she should obviously be
like whitelisted into being able to do
this
obviously and also i just think nbc
should like make this official like
they're so dumb also like the winter
olympics are struggling majorly like no
one cares even me i'm like such an
olympic freak and
you know you could use your mute to
cough just letting you know because i do
that sometimes
oh yeah like there's a music it's no
it's really nice
i didn't know it's going to be that big
of a cough okay but even if it's a small
cough like you should always just press
mute because that's this new interface
we're using it's like one of my favorite
because i could go like this ready
i just sniffled and nobody heard
did you hear okay i think people wanted
to hear me cough no i don't think that
they do but um i just don't understand
why nbc is like not actually using
leslie as an asset she is an asset
people are obsessed people are watching
the same amount of people are tuning in
to her instagram stories and her tick
tocks then are tuning into the olympics
i don't know why nobody's watching the
olympics even me like i can't be
bothered yeah i think that it's one you
know the plight of the winter games it's
just they're not in the summer games
there's a lot of controversy there's
just a lot of different things stories
coming out weirdness you know
quarantined food
it's bad it's bad
it's upsetting for an animal like myself
but
i have no desire to watch even when we
like shared last week about the opening
ceremony i was like expecting that i
would get into it i haven't turned it on
at this point i won't be turning it on
it's extremely weird the whole situation
is very weird
yeah i turn it on every day and i cannot
stay off my phone like i cannot focus on
any of these activities
yeah so at least like they should be
thanking leslie jones for like bringing
some relevancy to this extremely bizarre
time and broadcast and they should
really take her on in an official
capacity like she's [ __ ] hilarious
of course there's no reason
didn't they bring her to
rio
i hope so
but that was like six years ago now and
she's still doing it she's so funny
she's one of my favorite people to
follow on tick tock les dog like come on
yeah but i'm glad they're working it out
but still like you shouldn't have to
make it so difficult for her when at the
end of the day she's doing you a favor
literally bringing eyeballs to your like
train relevant program
a relevant program no disrespect to the
athletes because you guys are gorgeous
beautiful stunning and smart it's the
programming it's the marketing like it's
just not working
no disrespect to the athletes that's
what hurts to like have worked your
whole life and then to go and one it
feels like nobody cares but i'm sure
there's enough people that like hearing
their sponsors and they're like doing
all of the things that they typically do
but also i think as an olympian like
it's not a premium experience over there
have you seen the food that they're
getting but by the way like there's some
food i haven't seen the food but there's
always like
complaints about like the olympic
village and the cardboard beds where was
the last summer olympics like just
recently
uh
where the [ __ ] where was today we were
just watching um
tokyo
they were in
tokyo yes
there was all these tick tocks they were
literally sleeping on cardboard beds
there's always stuff like that so i
don't think that's what's like the core
of this problem i can't put my finger on
what it is but i don't think it's that
i think we know what it is but um
like we don't want this video taken down
what
there's just a lot of like political
issues oh in china you're saying yeah
yeah i just feel like there's not i'm
not feeling the olympic spirit
no not feeling the olympic spirit but um
i am hoping that the athletes you know
get their shine yeah and as someone who
has that spirit running through her
blood it's
it's very upsetting
yes
cool so those are the past five stories
very complex very complex you could see
how i had a difficult time ordering them
not one was so much more important than
another no it's true but you know you
did a great job because you're a great
girl thank you and i felt like the
olympics could lead us into the tv recap
because we are the olympians of
recapping television
all right the tv recap is brought to you
by paint your life when we heard about
paintyourlife.com we thought what a
great gift for someone else but also for
us
it's you would think it's expensive to
have like a full piece of art
commissioned for you personally but it's
really not you get a professional
hand-painted portrait created from any
photo at a really affordable price or
you can combine photos of people or
places you love into one painting choose
from a team of world-class artists and
work with them until every detail is
perfect user-friendly the platform's
user friendly so it makes it really easy
to order a custom made hand painted
portrait in less than five minutes and
it's super fast you can receive your
portrait in as little as two weeks so
send any picture i obviously sent a
picture of theo and it's on my theo
shrine it's one of my favorites it came
so fast it's gorgeous it's
unique it's special and it's really the
best gift like for anyone i know a lot
of people use this to like have photos
painted of people who have passed away
like you can really do it for anyone
it's so it's so different it's not like
other gifts it's actually really really
sweet um
and at paintyourlife.com there's no risk
if you don't love the final painting
your money's refunded guaranteed and
right now as a limited time offer you
can get 20 off your painting 20 off and
free shipping but only when you text the
word mornings to 64 000 that's morning
to 64 000 for free shipping and 20 off
text morning to 64 000. paint your life
celebrate the moments that matter most
message and data rates may apply terms
available at painterlife.com terms again
text morning to 64 000.
great thank you so much i love painting
your life what a thoughtful gift and
just like a great piece of art even for
yourself so i thought last night's
jersey was really interesting for me for
me there's two things going on the first
is like the gia melissa theresa joe
and then obviously the jennifer aiden
drama let's start with the first because
i feel like you know italian cultures
act and i talked about this on melissa
gorga's podcast so sorry if you're
hearing this for the second time but
italian culture is actually really
similar to like jewish culture in the
sense where like you have ultimate
respect for your elders and like
i'm sure for joe like to hear gia come
at him like that she was being like a
little disrespectful she's justified in
her feelings but i understand why it got
to like this chaotic place because he's
like what the [ __ ] is going on like that
just doesn't happen in italian families
right yeah if this was a conversation
between like say
teresa and joe
he would have been more receptive to the
way she was talking to him but from the
way that gia approached him from the
jump he was not going to be entertained
you're not going to entertain being
spoken to like that and i have to be
honest in that regard i do agree i felt
like when they were like all fighting in
the driveway like he wouldn't let her
like say her piece because he just like
was so blinded by the disrespect but i
think for him like it's blinding
and you also have to think like given
the context like i know that joe is
gia's dad i do and i respect that
but
i don't even think she can get into the
headspace of joe gorga like all that he
did for
for those kids when joe was put away and
then also the things like he made
personal sacrifices like you know his
parents being so stressed out like i
totally understand and it must be hard
to hear like
it's like gia doesn't even want to
acknowledge like the bad [ __ ] her dad
did and it's like i understand wanting
to see your parents in like a positive
light but like you also can be
delusional like he literally put your
mom in prison and he took years away
from your mom
spending time with her parents yeah no i
think joe gorga is totally justified in
his like
anger towards jojo dice i don't think
they'll ever you know squash it i don't
think they ever could because like of
what was lost what can never be brought
back like
as joe gorga would say he put his
parents in an early graveyard and
you know he sent his sister to prison
like this is these are real things and
everyone's like it was five years ago
like does that ever become fine no
right so
i understand that joe gorga will never
get over it i don't even think that he
necessarily should get over it
it's just gonna always be this wedge
between him and gia and like you can
feel how much he loves g and he doesn't
want there to be a wedge so i think he
would rather like
bring like air it out bring light to it
but she can't hear the truth it's too
painful for her yeah and i also have to
respect that because she has been
through so much and like she experienced
it you know
just as alongside with everyone yeah and
really like at a very
vulnerable and pivotal time in her life
so like everybody's entitled to how they
feel here yeah and typically the way to
resolve things is to talk it out but
talking about it is like making it worse
and so i don't know what they should do
you know i also really feel for melissa
because you can you can sense how much
she's trying to like deflate and just
minimize the situation because like they
like if if tr if joe and melissa like
actually told teresa like they swallow
so much if they actually told her every
time she but like they they would be
back where they were 10 years ago and
melissa i think is so afraid of being
back in that place that she swallows
everything and like this situation is
like blowing up right in front of her
and she's like she's not taking g aside
but she's trying to like come for gia
because they're so cl every fight they
have they're minutes away from being
back to the place with the christening
yeah yeah and she doesn't want that it
was a terrible time for melissa
yeah i agree and i also feel like teresa
doesn't do anything to help the
situation either she's just like
standing there watching when it's like
this should be teresa's fight but i mean
i guess theresa couldn't go to joe and
be like stop talking [ __ ] about like my
girl's father because it makes me
because joe is defending theresa joseph
and teresa here right
and you know how she loves to be
defended
that's why we gotta get joe judice back
in the states for one last hurrah
between joe and joe i'm not even
interested
joe on down interested we are going to
settle this
so the other part of the episode which
was super interesting was this event at
dolores says i just love dolores you
know why because
i get so frustrated with her because
she's like weirdly team jennifer and
teresa and the three of them are sitting
at that birthday party unable to see
their own hypocrisy i was like you guys
are delusional like literally
teresa is literally theresa did
something worse theresa had no reason to
go after jackie and she made it up
margaret has a million reasons to go
after after jennifer and it's true so
like the fact that they can't see like
how far up they are teresa's ass i was
like so disappointed in dolores but then
seeing her go out with margaret and like
get all the facts i was like i i had
some of my faith restored in dolores
because she's so
she's so like ethical like she's so
wise and she's she's princess
but she's always like using her
principles in the wrong in the wrong way
yeah i agree i'm just glad to see her
like come to the other side because it
is it's hard
watching ultimately i am team margaret
because like jennifer doesn't just get
to go around and say the things that she
does there are some caveats and i like i
think jennifer made a good point where
it's like with margaret everything that
jennifer has like judge margaret for are
things that margaret have shared so
you're taking something from the private
and then judging me for that but again
when you push and push and push someone
like they're going to come back swinging
and that's just how it is so i
generally like i i feel like margaret
was justified in being like let's
[ __ ] shut this [ __ ] down and why is
it after every reunion like jennifer and
at the ring it's like jennifer just like
goes scorched earth on all these women
and then it's
it's episode one and she has to come
with her tail between her legs like why
does she keep putting herself in this
[ __ ] position
anyways but i do
jennifer that like now this is out there
her kids are going to know and it's a
different situation like jackie said
because at the end of the day jackie
gets to tell her kids like this is a
rumor and jennifer is going to have to
tell her kids like this is what your dad
did and that's that's really hard and i
i have compassion for her
but of course
sometimes you need to learn things the
hard way and
to not push other people it's the
epitome of people in glass houses
shouldn't throw stones and she's [ __ ]
throwing bricks all for years now and
you know what
i've actually been enormously impressed
with jackie's behavior like i don't
think i could be that big of a person
like really wanting to help jennifer and
then like after all that she went over
to her house and she's cuddling her at
dolores house and then she hears that
jennifer is like still going around to
serena and tanafly finding pictures of
the girl evan [ __ ] like
she's relentless and she still can't see
why what's being done to her
they feel is justified she can't see
that even after all this
and she's just like i don't know i i'm
like jennifer like you're so big you
love to like come after everyone and the
we come for you and you're crying and
you have to go home like i'm like really
the
everything she's shown us up until this
point has been an act
you like you can dish it out but you
can't take it and this rule that like
you can only dish it out if it's false
information like so what we're trying to
do
that's teresa's twisted logic when she
said that at the table and it's it's so
crazy she's like rendering herself
irrelevant because of how illogical she
is to speak to and all of the women in
their confessionals were like yeah we
just don't even answer her whatever it
makes no [ __ ] sense but it's like
this is the star of the show and you
can't even have a conversation with her
it's so crazy like she
if i were her would shut her mouth when
it comes to everything about this
because it's like
everything that she says about it's like
well what about jackie and evan what
about what you did tevin what about what
you do jackie like you can't say one
thing about the situation without
thinking about what she did there like
obviously the opposite of principled uh
obviously and also this new housewife
coming in with like the worst take she
was so irrelevant then she had one um
interview scene and it's like defending
jennifer it's like girl that is not the
right take get the [ __ ] out of here i
don't know i think that if you came into
a situation and even though like melissa
and all her friends are saying like
jennifer's crazy she's so mean she's
done all this you come into the room and
this girl is sitting there crying and
everyone's like and her life i i could
understand being like this seems like a
lot well you know what i actually did
though think it was interesting some of
the details we got about the affair like
her being nine months pregnant and
giving birth the next day like that's
horrible
horrible but
i didn't realize it was 10 years ago i
thought it was like in the last few
years like while they were doing the
show sort of thing so it really is yeah
in the past
and the way that jennifer handled it is
like she totally acted like it didn't
happen didn't tell her friends her
family so now she's just like
her spots being blown up a bit
yeah and if you have a spot that's like
going to be blown up you shouldn't be
coming at everyone swinging so hard and
i think for margaret it's like you've
judged me so hard for having had an
affair when like the person that you
love has had an affair too i know other
people are like well obviously jennifer
judges margaret harshly because she's
been the scorned woman in that situation
right but it's like if you can you know
move on swiftly with bill
and plus like at the end of the day
margaret and joe had they they're
their relationships are different from
an affair but like they're completely
otp they've been together for so long
like at what point is it just you know
these things they do have it's
unfortunate but they happen sometimes
yeah like i don't know if i mean i can
acknowledge that i'm extremely biased
like i love margaret with all my heart
like i know her personally but i just
feel like it would frustrate me if i was
margaret that like nobody seems to give
a [ __ ]
like when they replay some of the stuff
jennifer said to her like your mother's
a [ __ ]
uh uh you were asking to be sexually
assault like
i
i would be annoyed that like none of the
women are as enraged like i understand
where margaret's rage is coming from
like it's not just the basic housewife
[ __ ] that jennifer has been saying
jennifer has been saying like some of
the most horrific demeaning things to
margaret for years so how these women
don't understand how annoyed margaret is
and margaret wants revenge like i can
understand that i'm a vengeful person
i agree i think that there is a real
double standard with the group and the
women like they expect
more from margaret than they do from
jennifer or teresa because they're
really like they do crazy and say crazy
things and like it's not held to like
the same standard as like when margaret
were were to do something or even like
jackie saying if it walks like a duck
quacks like a duck all of a sudden it's
the villain of the season right that's
the worst thing anyone could say to
teresa just saying something that's true
and
she like just alluding to the truth or
if you're you could control what your
husband did would he be like would you
have gone to jail
truth like and that was like the biggest
[ __ ] deal meanwhile jennifer and
theresa i feel like they kind of ignore
them and
and they expect like the women shouldn't
have their feelings so hurt by them
but
it's it's apples and oranges i i can't
these are we're all castmates like
you're all
adorable it's not a leveled playing
field yeah but it but it should be more
level even like theresa i was even
thinking last night about like the
teresa danielle style pulling margaret's
hair thing like if i'm margaret i'm i'm
still thinking about that i'm never
getting over that in my life like we can
have we can go on vacation and we'll
keep it here but we will never be
anything closer or deeper than that like
that's a line crust i will never forget
being a real housewife of new jersey
must be so frustrating because like you
are not entitled to like it's just not
it's not a fair game like teresa is just
on this pedestal and she gets away with
whatever and it's like it's so annoying
yeah and jennifer is kind of there too
because season after season like she
goes below the belt she like not
everything she says and does like really
adds up because she's very extreme but
she keeps coming back on the show people
love her i mean i really like jennifer
but it's it's like if you want to have a
fair fight you need to fight with one of
your friends because no one else is
gonna like your it's
apples and oranges yeah yeah um so it
was a pretty good episode it's actually
a really good kick off to the season i
don't know where this new girl is gonna
fit in because she seems so irrelevant
already but let's give her some time
yeah i i we need to get to know her on a
personal level so i can see like where
she slots in because she kind of seems
like similar to jackie and melissa and i
don't know what she
what new stuff she brings to the table
and there was another woman is she
supposed to be i don't think so but she
was cute she looked like uh they thought
she was theresa
yes she was cute she was cute i like
dolores new house i love dolores like i
just wish dolores could really wield her
power
it like
if and i know what dolores thinks like
she's a a smart person and if she could
actually say what she thinks and like go
against teresa like it would be gorgeous
but that would never happen no but
that's also because she's a principled
queen and and she's been friends with
theresa long before this show and she's
not just going to throw her under and i
have so much respect for that agreed
yeah um and then what did you think
about the gilded age okay so i only
watched the first episode but it was
really long it's literally like watching
a movie and it's so long i love the
gilded age period like i love that age
new york that time it's everything of
the sort so exciting
and so i'm really excited about the show
there were definitely elements of
community theater and that's also
because of like the accents you know the
way that they spoke back yes
it's like we're watching and it's like
why are you talking like that if you're
speaking it's not like a british accent
and you're speaking english so why are
you talking about right so it's hard to
watch it yeah totally
the russell woman um i think that she is
the biggest perpetrator of that uh and
it comes off the blonde one no the one
new money oh the mom
yeah
she's the worst like she's just so
obnoxious like i can't yeah so i think
that um
her acting gives a little bit of
community theater and there were
definitely times where sometimes it felt
stilted in that way but i love the
premise for the show and i had rece it
reminded me of this book that i read
called the social graces because it's
about um mrs astor
and um not consuelo alva vanderbilt and
they reference the real people in the
show even like mamie fish is a real
person and i think even that architect i
need to google him um
the architect who built their house yeah
i think he's let me just google it
really quickly i meant to do it last
night i think he's a real architect and
he like got into like a real
uh scandal
so i'm sure i like wonder if that's part
of this don't spoil it don't spoil it
he is a real architect hold on let me
just make sure that it's the scandal
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah okay i was right
so if they put like real historical
incidents
into the show like that's my favorite
kind of anything book tv show whatever
so i'm here for the premise on all
counts it definitely is gonna take a
minute to like warm up i am excited to
watch the second episode brew
loved it obviously there's pumpkin king
charles cavalier
oh yeah he felt extremely seen
any show that has a cavalier like i will
watch until the final episode of the
final season
i totally agree but like you could tell
like he whenever a dog barks or whatever
like he's like what was that right but
when he saw this dog he sat up at the
edge of the bed and just sat watching
like it was on a different level
if brew likes it i like it i'm excited
for the second episode hopefully they
find their groove more but i think it
has all the makings of something
fabulous i agree that cynthia nixon is
it's extremely distracting like
distracting like she's on and just like
that and the gilded age like i'm sorry
you can't at the same time you can't do
both
and like maybe there's an actor out
there who is that talented and diverse
that can do both at the same time it
ain't cynthia nixon
yeah so
that's my critique which i like her
character so it's fine
yes me too and also she's like very
anti-licious it's kind of like my
perfect ideal show it's auntielicious
totally
um i had one more thing to say [ __ ]
was it about the gilded age
i don't know i watched not a lick of tv
i was just so busy yesterday so that's
it for me on the tv recap but you did
watch new jersey yes that's it
shoot i forget what i was gonna say if
it was about guilty pregnancy brain
so scrambled oh
well if that's all from you that's all
from us if you're listening
i think it was a brew ting hold on let
me try let me try
pumpkin
the king charles
oh yes oh my gosh okay we got an
instagram comment yesterday that i found
so interesting that i need to share with
the class because when we were talking
about charles becoming king charles
someone explained why he's actually not
going to be called king charles
and okay here it is my british husband
just chimed in to let us know that
prince charles will not be called king
charles he'll be king george vii the
past two king charles's were horrible so
he doesn't want that line of succession
and his middle name is george so it
works out fine not fine for me but i
guess oh my god
first of all how are we going to
transition to calling him george from
charles first of all
second of all like the fact that we're
most likely going to be alive knock on
wood
during like a king george the seventh
year like that's giving 1776.
no king george the seventh is not an
icon he is not the moment and i think
that
you know what and maybe
if king charles is in the past have been
you know a bit mad it's just
perfect
he could turn the term around i think
charles if you're watching like please
don't do this be true to yourself your
awful self i know but you know they've
been doing for centuries where like when
you do ascend to the throne you do
change your name for
whatever reason um but i like it better
when they don't victoria didn't
elizabeth didn't i agree the icons
didn't i mean i guess you'd have to be
an icon to not change your name so maybe
it's it's george it's for the best i'm
glad you remembered that thank you for
sharing thank you i'm so glad that i did
too so if you're listening as a podcast
keep listening for the interview with
sophia i really hope you guys enjoy it
let me know what you think she's if
you're a sophia stan like you're gonna
love the episode and if you like didn't
know if you fell on the opposite side of
the call her daddy drama we can all be
we can all be civil and you i think
you'll really appreciate her perspective
it's um it's unique and i feel like she
doesn't really talk about this a lot so
i feel very privileged that she felt
open and
uncomfortable to talk about it because
it's a very painful time for her so um
enjoy the interview if you want to watch
it on youtube it's a totally separate
video than today's episode it's on our
channel um
and i'm so excited for you guys to hear
it and let me know what you think and
only let me know what you think if it's
positive cool thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast and
where podcasts can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have ready cast blocks all the places so
wherever you listen to podcasts find us
the morning shows and leave a five star
review about how beautiful
stunning
and smart we are hope you guys have an
amazing hump day do not forget to hump
someone you love
bye
bye